so you've been in LA five years if you
could rewind time what would be like
five things you wish you'd known right
away that you kind of had to learn by
just being here yes the number one
things number one thing is post cards do
not work scars don't work you know when
you come here the number one thing they
say actors has submit post cards you got
to send out postcards and irregular it
works what doesn't you know I would have
saved a lot of money just not sending
out postcards not submitting to agents
through mail they also tell you the
submit to agents and managers you know
send them your headshot real resume
that's a waste of money too
another thing I feel like is workshops
casting director workshops they're
beneficial but usually it can be a waste
of money I say it's only beneficial when
you really go to a casting director
who's looking for someone like you a lot
of actors don't just go to all the
casting director workshops that they can
and it may not be a good opportunity for
them because if this casting director is
you know typically casting something
like a American Horror Story or you know
the Pretty Little Liars something with
younger actors if you're older an older
actor that may not be the one for you so
it's like you just wasted your money
because that casting director is not
looking for older actors are looking for
younger actors or vice versa you know so
it can be a waste of money
something that was very essential for me
or was a casting director workshop for
soaps and that's actually how I got my
my sag card was going to a workshop for
Bob Lambert who at the time was casting
for all my children so I went to his
workshop it was a two or three day
intensive workshop I said hey you know I
just landed in LA I'm here fresh from
Kentucky he was like he's looking at my
resume he said you have no experience
but I would love to get you and set it
on my children and I get you some
experience so you can you know pick the
other actors minds and things like that
and learn something and so I got on
there I worked two episodes within 30
days and that's how I became sag AFTRA
and which was a blessing so that right
there was beneficial for me going to a
a casting director workshop for someone
who maybe casts Grey's Anatomy it's not
going to work for me because they're
looking for actresses who look like they
can play a doctor or maybe a nurse or
something like that I still look like
I'm a teenager so it's really hard for
me that's another thing that I would say
everything else to me is very essential
those were the two main things that I
would say I wish I knew before I moved
here
so it sounds like question when actors
actors are so preyed on don't spend
money on this for that so really
question all of those things are they
really necessarily absolutely they're
postcards and casting director workshops
are definitely not necessary it's a
waste of money what do you think about
people that are sag eligible but they
don't want to pay their dues yet until
they get closer to the role that they
want absolutely agree with you okay okay
absolutely agree I became a must join so
I had to join but I have a lot of
friends who are saggy sack eligible and
they're like hey I'm just waiting for
that perfect opportunity because what
happens is some producers their project
you know because it's not sag they don't
want to work with sag actors so they're
only looking for non-union actors to
work in this project because they don't
want to deal with the whole contract
thing and the union situation so I've
actually you know missed out on a couple
of roles because I was Union yeah so
it's um definitely I agree with that
with actors who decides the weight
you